from the moment I told the bull airs
their parents perished in a terrible
fire they've had adventures in all sorts
of exotic locales I've just dropped them
off at boarding school I know all about
you you've been sent to guardian after
Guardian and adversity has always
followed I'm afraid that you'll have to
live in a small tin shack craps our
chakras crabs our parents were a part of
something might be the reason all these
terrible things keep happening Count
Olaf is still looking for us
does this seem like a nightmare because
that's the effect I was going for
who is this man that's cut off in
disguise was in the middle of a scheme
to steal our fortune
what's saying man what disguise himself
four times in a row we lost our parents
in a fire we lost our parents as well
we've seen a lot of things we can't
explain like a spy boss
where did you get that there's a secret
room part of a mystery will never be
free until we figure out what it is we
have eyes everywhere and we are always
watch shape aiya
we don't have much time I think I've got
it
no please this time I have no mercy I
won't be satisfied with just your
fortune I will obliterate you
the cruelest way ambassador for the
camaraderie of this hospital is really
inspiring
I need to keep me I wish you luck
[Music]
I think you're going to need it this
episode in the lives the Baudelaires is
about to get much much worse
how's work sunny laughter you type like
a one-year-old
Oh
you